over the past weeks we have taken strong
measures to limit the spread of the
corona virus in the European Union
certain national governments have
introduced controls at internal borders
but we have one and a half million
people in the European Union who live in
one country and work in another they
need to cross the border to go to work
many of them have jobs that are
important for us all to get through the
crisis and this is why today we are
publishing practical advice to the
national governments on mobile workers
in the European Union the aim is to
ensure that these workers can reach
their workplace without delays while
taking precautions to keep them safe and
limit the spread of the virus member
states should establish simple and fast
procedures to ensure a smooth passage
for them with proportionate health
screening it is particularly important
that those working in sectors that are
critical to fight the corona virus can
reach their workplace rapidly these are
the people working in the healthcare
sector in childcare elderly care
firefighters and police officers
Transport Workers we need our doctors
nurses and all health workers to be able
to move rapidly from one country to
another for example the vast majority of
people working in hospitals in
Luxembourg live in France or Belgium the
health care system in Luxembourg would
suffer hugely if these workers were
several hours late every day because of
long waiting queues at the borders and
we need food and shops and on our dinner
table so we need those who produce it
and deliver to be able to move - we need
people to plant and harvest our crops we
have to make sure we have enough
seasonal workers in the agriculture
sector they help our farmers and they
want to earn the bread for their loved
ones at home of course under safe
working conditions
many hard-working Europeans help us
combat that virus together we will make
it easier for them to work safely